I'm afraid to touch it because the last
time I touched it it was so sticky we're
making galaxy
shiny slime I guess I've never made
slime before and I feel like it's
something that I need to be doing this
is sweeping the nation teen
entrepreneurs who are making a [ __ ] ton
of money at school by making slime this
looks like unicorn poop I'm gonna eat a
lot of glitter the more the merrier
this is very easy to get like carried
away with and just keep adding stuff to
it as a date this would be really such a
great idea
lime date you know I never thought this
slime thing would become such a big
thing oh wait we got some white glitter
how to stop baby Lou here I like this oh
my god I made the ugliest slime I'm so
upset
mine looks very Pinterest it's so
colorful like America so many colors am
I gonna have to mix this with my hands
at some point this is like the liquid
form of Las Vegas you know I went to
school to be a diplomat and now I'm
making slime for the internet it's like
we're a school Breaking Bad we're gonna
add borax now we're gonna do one to one
but you have to dilute it with water
this part is making me nervous
oh my created a literal monster looks
like the consistency is changing a
little bit it's already getting slime
like I added just at the small bag the
one's a breakfast house like going you
will get I have now added more glue
Alys is looking more and more like what
slime is supposed to look like and mine
looks less and less like it oh this is
kinda getting there it's getting there
I'm adding more of this Botox or
whatever and I feel like we're both
going a little crazy and we might be
ruining it well something has gone
terribly wrong in my slime world
she's pretty therapeutic this is not as
relaxing as I thought it was gonna be
I'd rather play with the stressful the
sound is really satisfying though Ashley
like I'm kneading pizza dough it's pizza
dough consistency at this point oh god
how did I ruin this it had so much
potential I was doing so well now mine
looks like so it's true we can make an
Instagram glam shot through the lips
doodle is like I am enjoying it though
I don't think I'll be able to sell it
but I think I enjoy the process of it
final thoughts are pride cometh before
slime we really thought we were doing
well and that this was easy-peasy
I was hoping by the end of today I would
have a beautiful slime ball to show off
and this is what I must live I'm gonna
watch hundreds of slime videos right
after this and then make a perfect slime
good night internets and good luck
Wow
[Music]